comic book icon Stanley's wife Joan has  died  [Music]  et can confirm joan died Thursday  morning surrounded by family she was 93  years old a spokesperson for the leaf  family released a statement to ET that  read in part quote the family asks that  you could give them time to grieve and  respect their privacy during this  difficult time Stan and Joan married in  1947 this December would have marked  their 70th wedding anniversary the comic  book legend credits much of his success  to his supportive wife he told The  Hollywood Reporter last year that Joan  inspired him during a time he  contemplated quitting the industry that  specific motivation led him to create  the Fantastic Four Joan is survived by  her husband Stan and their daughter Joan  Celia  [Music]